I want to talk a little bit more about
Hillary Clinton and again I've been I've
been hard on Hillary Clinton not
unfairly I believe and we talked last
week about excerpts from her new book
what happened and I said she seems to
have a total lack of understanding about
the Bernie movement a lot of blame game
stuff going on people slamming me saying
I'm not being fair I'm a Bernie bot blah
blah blah I did vote for Hillary Clinton
right and I voted for Hillary Clinton in
the general election because I thought
she was the best candidate people said
why didn't you vote for Jill Stein since
you were in Massachusetts I actually
believed that Hillary Clinton was a
better choice than Jill Stein in the net
but I'm not interested in when we put a
different way I'm mostly interested in
analyzing arguments and assertions and
some of these came in the form of
Hillary Clinton's first major interview
since her election loss which was
yesterday on CBS Sunday morning and she
was asked well what mistakes did you
make what what is to blame for your
election loss and as far as mistakes go
she said straight up using personal
email was a major mistake see also sort
of seemed it with less direct language
to say she didn't realize I'm
paraphrasing this was my impression that
she didn't realize how Donald Trump's
rhetoric even though it seemed so crazy
and and off-putting
it actually would appeal to a lot of
white voters who were still angry about
the recession or whatever else okay so
she listed some specific mistakes she
also listed other things that she
believes influenced why she lost that
I'm gonna play that clip for you now
okay and try to keep a count of how many
things Hillary Clinton points to you
here
I went from I think 26 points ahead to
13 points ahead and I needed about 18
points in order to be sure I could win
Pennsylvania I watched how analysts who
I have a great deal of respect for like
Nate silver burrowed into all the data
and said but for that Comey letter she
would have won so it was very personal
to me I think my general election
prospects were so badly damaged because
of
that even though I was starting to come
back it was not enough time to overcome
it but even though that was the primary
blow to my campaign at the very end it
has to be looked at in context with the
Russians weaponizing information
negative stories about me this whole
WikiLeaks beginning to leak in early
October of John Podesta Z mails which if
you've read them all
they're pretty anodyne but they were
taken out of context the stories were
made up about them we now know facebook
was taking money from Russian companies
to run negative stories about me
if you look at all of this yes it
affected me and my campaign but I am
more concerned now going forward that we
haven't come to grips with what it means
for future elections I would also add
that the voter suppression that we now
know had been in the works and really
put into effect in a lot of states like
Wisconsin North Carolina etc played a
role and then let's not forget sexism
and misogyny which are endemic to our
society and certainly as I write in my
chapter called on being a woman in
politics have to be factored in okay
there was a lot there let's put up the
list of the reasons Hillary Clinton
cited for why she lost and I bear with
me because you need nuanced
to think about this okay Hillary Clinton
stated in that one minute and 58 second
clip she lost because the James Comey
letter damaged her that's that's true I
agree with that that the James Comey
letter did damage her she lost because
Russia weaponized negative stories about
Hillary Clinton they did do that and it
probably had some influence
she lost because of WikiLeaks releasing
John Podesta Z mails
maybe I mean it was very close almost
anything could could have some impact
she lost because Facebook took money
from Russian companies for negative
stories she lost because of voter
suppression she lost because of sexism
and misogyny endemic to society
she's not wrong right I mean when it's
this close if any one of those fact most
of any of those factors had been
different could have flipped the
election so when she says that you can
take any one of those six items and
build a case as to why it did make a
difference but that doesn't change that
it never should have been this close it
never should have been this close when
you're running against Donald Trump
there should have been some better
approach from the beginning to actually
being progressive Hillary Clinton was
not particularly likable she could have
listed right
if we're playing the game of when it's
this close any one thing could have
flipped the election if she had been 10
points more likeable with identical
policy positions same politics right
just 10 points more likable six points
more likable we're talking about what
was at 77,000 votes across three states
so it's very difficult to have these
conversations because some people say
David she's just right she lost because
of those things it was so close and
you're not wrong at the same time why
was it even this close and you can look
at the DNC you can look at the fact that
a lot of Hillary Clinton's position
seemed just forced in order to appeal to
whatever she thinks is the the wins of
polling of the day so if we're gonna
play the let's pick one thing we can do
that with things that make Hillary
Clinton seem blameless and things that
makes Hillary Hills make seem Hillary
Clinton we be a full of blame but I
think that that's the wrong approach the
pick one thing because it's never one
thing I just feel like when you lose to
the most unpopular presidential
candidate of all time you don't get to
pick the reasons why you don't get to
really list those you have to look
inward a little bit more if you're going
to because you mean you can take some
personal responsibility you could have
gone to those states like Wisconsin and
Michigan I mean you could have Hillary
Clinton lost 53% of white women voters
right so how can you point to sex of and
misogyny you really can't I think that
once we say let's pick one thing and
just blame that anybody can pick
whatever they want and I think you're
absolutely right and to be super clear I
don't actually
think that Democrats really need to
change or let me put in a different way
Democrats need to change a lot Trump's
win doesn't really change anything for
Democrats moving forward Democratic
failures have been similar for a long
time Democrats need to actually be
progressive and take principle positions
on big issues including health care like
I've been talking about and I think that
everybody will probably find something
they disagree with in my analysis of
this but I think the entire way this is
being framed in a black-and-white way is
totally decent disingenuous talk about
this with me on reddit david pakman.com
slash re d di t today's episode is made
possible in part by zip recruiter if
you're hiring you need to know where to
post the job to find the best candidates
which can be difficult thankfully with
zip recruiter you can post your job to
over a hundred job sites with one click
and then zip recruiters technology will
efficiently match the right people to
your job
that is why zip recruiter is different
unlike other job sites zip recruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds candidates for you and in fact
over 80% of employers who post a job on
zip recruiter receive a qualified
candidate within 24 hours you don't have
to juggle emails calls to your office
you can screen rate and manage
candidates all in one place with zip
recruiters easy-to-use dashboard and you
can find out today why zip recruiter has
been used by businesses of all sizes to
find the most qualified job candidates
with immediate results and my listeners
and viewers can post jobs for free
unzip recruiter that's right for free if
you go to zip recruiter dot-com slash
Pakman that's zip recruiter dot-com
slash
PA que ma N one more time try it free at
zip recruiter dot-com /pa que ma n